але вам не соромно буде натискати кнопку
за те що військові поранені з
ампутаціями будуть декларуватися А оці
жирні морди які крадуть живуть на
корупційні конверти присутні на всіх
нарадах не маючи допуску не маючи
допуску до держтаємниці управляючи вами
вказуючи вами Як вам голосувати
підміняючи собою уряд даючи вказівки
кожному з вас вони декларуватись не
будуть вам не соромно але вам не соромно
буде натискати кнопку за те що військові
поранені з ампутаціями будуть
декларуватися А оці жирні морди які
крадуть живуть на корупційні конверти
присутні на всіх нарадах не маючи
допуску не маючи допуску до держ
таємниці управляючи вами вказуючи вами
Як вам голосувати підміняючи собою уряд
даючи вказівки кожному з вас вони
декларуватись не будуть вам не